[Music]
identity and democracy or ID for short
is a new group in the European
Parliament which replaces Europe of
Nations and freedom its priorities are
jobs and growth security and Thecla
illegal immigration with 73 MEP identity
and democracy is the fifth largest group
in the European Parliament we have to
focus on the policies that can bring
common benefit to people we do it
together and live other policies at the
national level so our message is that we
want a mere opinion that is less
bureaucratic the simpler and is it is
closer to the EU citizen most of its
members come from Italy's League party
the National Rally in France and the
German party AFP it has any piece from
six other countries Austria Belgium the
Czech Republic Denmark Estonia and
Finland we are a pragmatic group that
like to challenge the view of the there
is no alternative rhetoric that someone
uses in the European Union in the last
2025 years every time that we are facing
a problem in the European Union this
solution that the former majorities in
the European Parmenter proposed it to
the US citizens walls we need to
delegate more power to Brussels
[Music]